the woman the myth the skinny legend is
back in the building
Trixie Mattel is here I'm back I'm a
wizard named Carol thank you for having
me back again thank you for coming I was
so excited to see your name back in my
email INBOX said get her here you had
There like remember you had to Google me
I'd remember who I why look at some
reference photos Nick that's the one
yeah that's I don't have a restraining
order against that one yes he can come
back the camera went down for a moment
and I turned to RuPaul and I said oh my
god I was like I just want to say thank
you so much
like I it is such an honor to be here
such a pleasure to meet you have no idea
like what this just giving her you know
that whole like everything I've ever
wanted to say to her and she turned to
me and she said nothing you say matters
unless that camera is rolling and that
broke my spirit wow there's all this
drama with pearl basically saying RuPaul
said save it for the show when she tried
to talk to her what do you make of all
that um it only I mean I'm only gonna
talk about it if these cameras are on
well they're on see think the green
lights the red lights they're there um I
know I mean unfortunately it was fern
that happened in an episode where I was
just eliminated so all those people can
live forever die tomorrow I was gone and
I was just freshly crying home to
Wisconsin when that episode happened
so I bet you I was like you know house
mad I'm sure right but I don't know I
can't speak to it
fair enough can you speak to the future
of the Trixie and Katya show well again
RuPaul's the executive director or
executive producer on it and if I talked
out of line I'm sure you would see like
a red dot on my head no just like and
you hear that laughs yeah yes so we
don't we might get more we might not get
more we don't know well we're very lucky
at this point in American history to
have a very healthy and much happier
Katya mm-hmm and as always a very
sprightly trace in the towel so
hopefully that happens and if it does
you'll be the first to know I want to
see more of it thank you very much um
working together with Katya either
YouTube's more on television for me was
the most rewarding thing I've ever done
with drag we're doing drag race more
than any of it it's the I'm the I'm more
proud of my time with Katya on YouTube
and television than anything ever done
well you and Katya as panel at drag can
be the your first like professional
reunion since she went away I think so
yeah yeah if you guys are gonna be a
drag concoct inai are doing what we do
best which is we're getting together and
sort of the drag contracting Katja show
is fun because it's me and Katya and
then our third character is the audience
so they ask questions one time this girl
read erotic fan fiction about the new
love you yes which was a not not super
welcome but it happened it's an
experience in your life yeah but I work
with Katya so I'm used to be
uncomfortable what's the weirdest fan
question you've ever oh I mean I mean
I've experienced I've experienced the
highs and lows where they're dressed as
me or they get up to me in faint I would
say on a daily basis I meet three young
women who cry that's on a daily basis on
a daily basis Oh crying and then lows
where people get up to me and they panic
and they get an emotional where they
just like get up to the line and they're
like Trixie I was abused and I'm like
okay well it's 1:00 p.m. at the Javits
Center so do you want a hat gonna buy a
pin I don't know what to do but um you
know it's cotton eyes openness with our
own highs and lows that I think makes
those floodgates open for people so I
welcome it come cry come cry with me a
drag con I mean who can say that they
put on wigs and accidentally emotionally
stimulate people I'm a drag queen
yeah only like yes only a handful of
drag queens yeah
or people say um specific things like
hey you're some this song you wrote
really like change this part of my life
or um you encanta did an episode on god
that made me feel really good about my
relationship with God stuff like you
never think yeah I don't know I don't
want to sound cheesy but don't tell
anybody that I doesn't make me happy
don't tell anybody it's just between us
here yeah I like to maintain that I'm
like too cool for it but it really makes
me feel good
[Applause]
[Music]